[Music]
so as you know most of you that listen
regularly we've been on the air now for
a little over 25 years even before I was
on the air I was teaching people about
money when I first started this stuff
I'm a math nerd I've got a degree in
finance I had all the letters and
licenses after my name and all the
different things and you know I was real
concerned about the math really
concerned about the math and I would sit
down with people and show them how to
get out of debt
and they would go home and promptly not
do it it was really frustrating I and I
started figuring out that hope has more
to do with you winning with money than
math does because hope gives you what's
fuel on the fire it gives you a reason
to make changes a reason to do something
you've never done before and really what
we're saying here is is that personal
finance is about 80-percent behavior
it's only about 20% head knowledge and
math the problem with your money is not
your math probably your money is a
person in your mirror they're screwing
up everything I can get the guy in my
mirror to behave he'd be skinny and rich
right that's what I figured out so I
quit telling people to get out of debt
paying off the highest interest rate
first I start teaching people we started
calling that we started calling we
started calling the debt snowball and
that's a real you know real tough
metaphor to grasp you list your debts
smallest to largest you pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
when you attack the little one with a
vengeance scorched earth lifestyle sells
so much stuff the kids think they're
next take 16 extra jobs name the dog
eBay and put him there put the cat on
Craigslist we're getting out of debt
we're getting out of debt
and you pay everything you stopped all
investing temporarily and completely
focus all your emotional spiritual
financial relational energy on that
smallest debt everything goes on that
when that one's gone you take the
payment that used to be there and any
other money we can squeeze out of our
budget and we throw it at number two and
when that one's gone then we take the
payments from one and two
the snowball rolls over again it picks
up more snowing you attack number three
the average person for the past 25 years
that has done that with great focused
intensity intention ality
gone crazy to the point they're broke
friends and relatives thought they
needed counseling they shaved their head
that drank the kool-aid they get out of
debt in about 18 to 24 months everything
but their house that's the average now
some of you got a lot of debt it takes
you five years some of you get out of
debt in four months but the average is
between 18 and 24 months it works
millions tens of millions of people have
gotten out of debt debt-free screams
alone on the air here last year were
forty nine point eight million dollars
that's kind of like 50 million dollars
and that was just the ones that screamed
on the air other people just stood in
their backyard and screamed and that
work too you know you want to come on
the air for it to count you're out of
debt shut up Dave you oughta the wave
Ramsey our Sargon's Witter Dave Ramsey
doesn't teach the most optimum way to
get out of debt the most optimum way to
get out of that is to list you paid off
highest interest rate first says the
[ __ ] on Twitter I used to be that [ __ ]
I tried that the problem is it doesn't
work so let me explain to you what
optimum means optimum is the one that
works not the one that's mathematically
correct honey if we were doing math we
wouldn't have credit card debt to start
with this is not a math problem this is
a you problem
it's personal finance it's more behavior
it your success with your finance has
more to do with you getting along with
your spouse and being on the same page
than it does mathematics
you can be a freaking math genius and
you and your spouse aren't on the same
page and all of our data tells us you
will not win with money you will not
build wealth you could not build wealth
in spite of a princess or in spite of a
prince who spends money like they're in
Congress I can't do it you can't make
enough money to outspend stupidity or
outturn stupidity I tried it not my wife
I was the stupid one I always thought if
I just made a little more it'd be okay
no I had to learn to control what I had
so we start teaching people class called
Financial Peace University the class is
about 25 years old start teaching it
with an overhead projector in a bad suit
was $569 to go through the class four
people came the first night three of
them bought $569 the class was 26 weeks
long from everett 13 lessons come every
other week for six freaking months got
stopped by here the other day that was
in that very first class good to see him
I hadn't seen him in a long time we got
to be friends he his wife and yeah hi
and he's a multi-millionaire now by the
way why because I gave him money I
didn't give him any money I just showed
him how to do it and he did it he
followed the steps that we teach in
Financial Peace University not only the
baby steps
not only the debt snowball but also
started investing in good mutual funds
over a long period of time that's 25
years he should be a multimillionaire
you do this stuff it works
that's what popped him um is morons you
people that are calling me out and it's
not optimum let just tell you optimum is
what works
that's what's optimum not what's
mathematically correct
I understand that that snowball is not
mathematically correct and I don't
really care my math nerd down the side
of me cringes but I don't really care
what matters is what works how it allows
you to change your life Financial Peace
University now includes every dollar
plus
a year where you connect to your bank it
now includes you get a 1-year access to
the online assets meaning you can watch
the videos and audios and everything
else all online for a year and of course
now it includes free shipping it's only
a hundred and twenty nine dollars it
includes the kit you can join a class in
your area by the way you're almost too
late don't be too late it's January we
have sixteen hundred classes starting
this week next week so you need to get
your kit like right now there's over
5,000 starting in the month of January
alone next week there's sixteen hundred
starting so you need to jump in there
and get your Financial Peace University
kit get in your local class in the area
use the online stuff all the every
dollar which is the world's best
budgeting app it's all included this is
the best deal we've ever done on
Financial Peace University it does not
get any better than this and here's the
trick its optimum because it works
check it out Dave Ramsey comm back with
your calls right here on the Dave Ramsey
show